the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i'm ryan sickler and
i can't thank you enough uh for your
support man this community continues to
grow my goal was 2 000 subscribers i
think we're just about 1900
uh so thank you for your support and if
you or someone you know has that story
that needs to be heard please submit it
to honeydewpodcast gmail.com we're gonna
vet em hopefully we get to do an episode
with you uh we are getting some wild
[ __ ] stories in i love my goddamn job
all right it's five bucks a month you
now get the honeydew
audio and video a day early ad-free at
no additional cost five bucks so if
you've been thinking ah do i go for the
year go for the year you get a month
free all right that's the deal there it
is and um
we're going to be talking to a guest
this week highlighting the low lights
this is a story we have not heard yet so
i get excited when we get brand new
trauma rolling up in this [ __ ] ladies
and gentlemen please welcome i'm gonna
look at your name so i don't [ __ ] this
up andre speedo welcome to the honeydew
with y'all andres feed it did i get it
right hello yeah you good you're good
first first person in a while all right
i did i had to write it phonetically and
then look it up
uh andrei uh welcome to the honeydew
with you all thank you for being here
where right now are you on planet earth
all right now i am in great meadows new
jersey uh not too basically not too far
from hackettstown where they make all
the m m's in the world that's the only
thing our town is good for okay
um how old are you
all right now i'm 27. all right and uh
what do you do for a living
so recently i just started my own
massage therapy company i'm still
waiting on uh sid the sloth uh governor
murphy to allow us to do travel but uh
until that opens up i'm pretty much just
waiting for the go to get on massaging
all right so you're 27 your story you
submitted is different than anybody i
mean we've talked to people who've uh
several people who've had different
biological parents all these things
but you suffered a fall
um and it really caught my attention
especially after what tom's injury we
were taught you mentioned in there you
realize what he went through so
uh let's hear about it because this
thing sounds pretty [ __ ] gnarly
all right so
this goes back to about august
7 2018 uh
so it was a tuesday uh earlier
yeah
yeah so i had to catch a plane that
friday to go back home to my home
country ukraine uh so i took the whole
week off from i didn't feel like going
to work oh i thought that was a jersey
accent i was hearing this whole time
yeah no [ __ ] dude no [ __ ]
whole crazy story with that but we'll
get into that another day all right
so basically i was going on a different
hiking trail than i normally would but
it's just backwards the same trail i
traveled hundreds of times to this
overlook but backwards and you you've
never done this backwards before
no so i walk up to this giant cliff face
which would have been the bottom of the
overlook which i normally go to
now i've had
a novice experience with rock climbing
i've done it a couple times with friends
this down a third this time i'm by
myself which should have been a giant
red flag right
uh i don't have any ropes i don't have
any gear so i'm like yeah
it doesn't look too bad so i talked
myself into it i'm like i'll be i'll be
able to climb up i'll be back in my car
in about an hour two hours now
mind you i was doing great i start
climbing i get up the wall but you're
free climbing
yeah okay i i've watched even before
that free solo i still look for it
there's i think it might even be that
[ __ ] kid but there's this video of
this young kid i watched he chalks his
hands
and he goes up [ __ ] half dome and
[ __ ] and there's a family at the top
that's on the overlooking like where the
[ __ ] you come from he's like
and nothing no gear but one of them
and it's things you have to you know
consider i always was tripped out by
those guys that hold the bar and cross
that
tight wire across skyscrapers and [ __ ]
but um
he got up
maybe three quarters of the way
and backed up against the wall and the
winds were going it was foggy and he he
finally the anxiety hit him
and it's too late you're not going down
now at that point so he had to [ __ ]
sit there for a while gather himself and
then continue the rest of the way
so you decide you're gonna go
and you've nev you said you've had some
some experience rock climbing have you
ever free climbed ever
so
mind you i've reclined this one spot
before but i had two other friends with
me now and that was like six years prior
so i'm thinking like i've done this
before i remember this wall so i'm like
i'm climbing up comfortably and doing
great i get to like this one spot where
i can chill out catch my breath
just as soon as i get uh start going
back up i get a little bit higher a
little bit higher and right at the top
i'm crawling over the top no
it's like you're there
at the top yeah i was one foot on top of
the [ __ ] thing my arm i'm literally
wrapped around the boulder i'm just
getting my foot around and my arms just
let go
i don't know what happened
whether it was the wind
my muscles just gave out but it was like
time stopped for a split second it was
like that and i remember just looking
around and just saying [ __ ] in slow
motion because everything just started
to go slowly in front of me down
so instantly and how are you are you
flipping or are you that classic uh uh
lethal weapon just falling straight back
like air mattress [ __ ] or what how are
you falling so i have the rock wall in
front of me and i'm holding on and as i
let go i'm just literally like this far
away like this far away from the rock
wall just i'm just trying to grab on to
things i'm pressing my feet into the
wall oh as
as i'm it's just a straight down like i
went up the side and went around to this
to the overlook so it's just a straight
down
so i'm just sliding down pressing
pressing pressing and i remember at one
point i hit this wrist against i'm
pretty sure a boulder or something a
tree but i didn't think anything of it
sliding i land on my feet right come on
standing up standing up right i feel
this like
this cold metal feeling go from my foot
up through my body and out my head right
you fell how far
the whole 60 feet you fell 60 [ __ ]
feet and landed on your [ __ ] feet
yup
what are the [ __ ] odds of that
mind you if i didn't try to grab the
wall and press my feet and grind my
shoes into dust going down
i would not be here to tell the story
all right so hold on were your feet
actually touching and like skidding down
they were actually hitting okay so you
weren't just they were not not straight
i was grabbing i was literally like
touching the wall any way i can just to
slow myself down any friction connection
i could oh god right so
i land on my feet and my first instinct
into is like
oh take a deep breath i'm like all right
i'm alive that's the first thing i say
i'm alive let me grab my phone i pull
off my string bag i pull out my phone
and i see that my phone is cracked in
half
because i guess it hit it going down on
going down the wall i smacked the side
of the wall and just smashed so
i didn't think anything of this i sat
down
and then when i was sitting down i
started to feel like a weird pain so i
laid down on the ground for a second
once i laid down i could i was lifting
my neck and that was about it my whole
body was non-responsive paralyzed
yeah so
all right at that moment let's stop
right there all right you just fell 60
feet you land on your feet your phone's
broken you're solo
you
sit down to catch your breath and then
you lay down and once you're down your
body shuts down so right before i laid
down i forgot this part um once i landed
i started to feel my eye start to swell
shut like you know how boxers after a
couple rounds they suck so i knew
instantly
i got to cut that open so i don't have a
blade i don't have anything so i in that
moment i look at my fists i use this
side of my knuckles and i just hit
myself at an angle and if you can see
there's a little scar right here from
where i pop
oh yeah it was
hold on
you didn't even know what it was though
why not leave it why not leave it
swollen
i felt it start to swell and i started
to like lose sight in that eye i was
like i know that if i let that [ __ ] stay
swollen i'm gonna lose that eye like i
don't want i don't want to lose it i
figure [ __ ] it if i'm still here alive
there has to be a reason so i gotta at
least try to save and you [ __ ] jacked
yourself in the face oh yeah one shot
one good shot and now with the now with
the full just with these knuckles
because they're did blood and [ __ ] shoot
out all shot out all the swelling went
away and my vision returned right away
man all right all right so now
are you in pain or are you numb
like your body no pain
so i'm not completely numb but i'm also
not in pain i'm in like this
shock that i landed the fact that i
landed and i'm still alive yeah just
took
blocked all the paint out so you you
can't even your body's non-responsive so
you can't even pinch your legs to see if
you feel nothing nope
what time of day is this
so this was around five o'clock that
tuesday
p.m yeah p.m
all right and when was it what month of
the year
so this is august so you gotta you got
about three hours of daylight ish left
yeah okay and your phone's broken is
this a populate heavy heavily populated
area
nope
and i'm by myself so it doesn't even
help okay
so you you realize my body doesn't work
what's next what do you do next
so my next thing is all right
that's what i'll be doing [ __ ] i
tried that one i tried that one twice
and i realized if i'm gonna keep yelling
i'm just gonna burn myself out i got i
don't have limited energy
so i was like let me let me cool this
down
did you hear your own echo and [ __ ] come
back oh
listen hold on hold on how lonely is it
to be
quadriplegic in the [ __ ]
wilderness
at sunset
and to scream and the only thing you
hear back is your [ __ ] scream my god
dude that is terrifying
that and the worst part of it the road
is like maybe a thousand feet
out of the woods so i just hear every
once in a while a car just drive by
god
damn are you hoping to get out to take a
piss or something
oh my god dude
i would have i would have stopped for
anybody i would have even even if a cop
came i would have accepted it um
i gotta ask i gotta ask you this dude
how long did you have a watch how did
you keep time did you
the sun the sun and the moon huh yeah
amazing um
how long into this did you start crying
about a month month and a half
what
all right so let me let me fill in
i did not let this get to me
until i knew i'm talking about let's
focus here for i just want to keep you
focused because we're paralyzed on the
ground right now we've never been there
so i want to know about this
are you are you are you
keeping your head at this point are you
panicking are you crying like where are
you at this moment all right so so
mentally i knew that all right i i have
my checklist i'm alive and i can breathe
so i cross that off i know number three
does my limbs work and we we gotta we
gotta know
so
my next step is like all right i have in
my mind i remember watching a lot of
survival shows remember you can survive
like three days without water or six
days without food or something like that
so i'm like all right i'm good at least
until friday they could at least find me
by friday and i should be fine so that
kept my my mental calm the whole way
because i'm like man i still got two
more days before i should start
panicking did you have breakfast that
morning
oh yeah always always good breakfast
i i didn't i wasn't hungry because the
body shuts that right off as soon as you
get hurt i didn't have to go to the
bathroom because that was gone after
that so i'm laying there
and now it's starting to get andre andre
be careful when you're hitting your
table there it's coming through really
loud i got you i got you my bad um
so uh like i was saying i'm laying there
and i see the sun start to set so i'm
thinking all right
i know i don't have a concussion because
i could still say words without jumbling
them
you you can talk out loud you're talking
out loud yeah yeah and i'm testing your
vocabulary i hadn't even thought of that
one
oh my god i mean what else am i gonna do
that's good
my phone's dead i got no watch
are you [ __ ] worried about it being
too cold are you worried about [ __ ] that
i'm worried about a bear
coming to anything coming to get me
snakes
so
i have i'm like i'm pretty cool when it
comes to hiking in nature so i don't let
animals really bother me like yeah
because you can usually get away though
now you're just [ __ ] trapped
so here's the thing right i'm laying
down i'm thinking like man i guess a
bear if they wanted to could walk up on
me but bears in new jersey are all obese
they'd rather go for garbage than people
any day
so i figured all right the worst case
i'll probably have a coyote or something
run up on me thinking i'm dead and all i
do is yell
so i remember laying
it's probably like it's it's dark so
it's probably like nine o'clock 10
o'clock i remember hearing some rustling
i'm like oh joy something's coming my
way oh jesus christ
so it gets closer closer and then like
it's probably like 30 yards away i give
a good yell and it just books it the
other way so i was like all right i got
nothing to worry about
now
in the meantime i'm laying there and i
start to feel like this
like this warm on my head so
naturally i start to feel around and i
feel like this divot and i kid you not i
stick my finger up to this knuckle into
my head oh you got a [ __ ] hole in
your head that deep
yeah so when i landed i guess the shock
from when my foot connected with the
ground traveled through my body and blew
out the top of my head blew out the top
i don't think that happened
i don't know exactly i don't know
i didn't hit my head alright i know that
cause
the whole fall i was like i just gotta
make sure i don't hit my head i don't
hate my head and then all right no
[ __ ] electricity shot through
your goddamn skull
no way
[Music]
a twig a stick sticking out something
got you on the way down you just don't
know it cause you're probably
probably honestly i honestly i probably
did it to myself
[Music]
okay so now you're now are you panicking
now are you like oh [ __ ] so still in
this moment i'm still not feeling pain
and i still have my like my in my mind
i'm like you know what my girlfriend at
the time hikes this area i'm hoping
tomorrow she'll be hiking here and since
i didn't come home she'll come looking
for me so i'm like all right i'll just
wait until tomorrow so i'm calm i've
calmed down i take a little nap you
actually do you're able to fall asleep
oh yeah
but you're not worried about this whole
pumping blood out of your [ __ ] head
right now so so what i didn't know was
bleeding i i just i knew there was a
hole oh wait i thought you stuck your
finger in it that deep and saw blood
so i i stuck my finger but there was
just so much dirt and everything else
around that it by the time i saw my
finger it was all
dirty and like
mud yeah so
at the time i i still have use of my
arms just not my lower legs and my upper
body okay so now your your arms are
coming back yeah yeah that was the first
all right so hold on i got another are
you are you under brush are you
are you covered or are you just laying
in dirt like at the bottom of this cliff
i'm basically uh i'm under a couple
trees but there's no bushes or anything
around just trees and then all the
downed leaves from the from the trees in
the fall
so in that moment i decided you know let
me gather some leaves let me at least
make my head comfortable because i'm
laying on rocks so i lift my neck up a
little bit with some leaves now
i didn't think this through thoroughly
thinking now that i have a hole in my
hand this whole day went to [ __ ] when
you went to backwards way bro
exactly exactly
so
i uh i didn't think anything of it so
i'm bunching these leaves in this dirt
together to make a little pillow for
myself whatever
i'm comfortable enough i make it through
the night i fall asleep i sleep through
the night i wake up as the sun's coming
up naturally you know
so now it's like all right it's day two
and i'm still nobody's around
so wait the sun comes up you see the sun
come up
how many times since you quit yelling
for help have you yelled again have you
tried again a new a new day a new dawn
are we throwing out some new helps
so i did and uh i did call help but it
was a spanish one because i heard
landscapers across the street
uh
so i tried english wasn't happening so
i'm just like
it wasn't happening either since uh no
one's gonna come check out why there's
help coming from the woods when i used
to have an old retired cop car so
anytime you see a cop car sitting on the
side of the road no one's gonna come
near it so i could be yelling to help
help help but the spanish guys could be
like no no that's a cop over there
they're trying to [ __ ] with us
so that was the main reason nobody
really stopped there uh check on that
hiking trails because there's a cop car
what do you got like an old crown vic
yeah at the time i had an 04 crown vic
at the time with the push bar the
spotlight you know
just a way to get down from uh down
through jersey the fastest on the
highway without worrying about it so
nobody's stopping nobody's uh helping
out so i'm just laying there i'm like
now it's starting to get like around
noonish because i feel the sun really
coming up and i'm just like all right
i'm laying here and then i look over my
arm and my arm is this big it is purple
and swollen and i'm just like oh joy
[ __ ]
and what are you wearing by the way just
shorts and a t-shirt yep a tank top and
jean shorts so the east coast i know
that even in the summer at night and
it's not like california at least it
dips 30 degrees at night out here in the
60s 50s but there it'll still stay in
the 80s so yeah august you're probably
comfortable enough all right
but now your arm is [ __ ] yeah
completely purple we had a nice humid
summer so it wasn't too bad at night but
i look over and my arm is just huge like
three times the size it should be for
black and blue and i'm like well i guess
i can't use that for now so
i'm yelling help to these spanish guys
i'm yelling yelling up and i hear their
land i wait for the lawn mowers to turn
off
then i try again
nothing then i hear their truck start up
and leave so i'm oh great
[ __ ] alone again oh yeah i'm alone again
so
with my hopes i'm just like somebody's
gotta have to [ __ ] take a hike here
somebody has to do something here like
there's no way nobody's gonna come here
on a wednesday
but nah so the day slowly starts to pass
it's starting to get around night time
again i'm like all right [ __ ] now i'm
starting to worry a little bit because
it's like okay
it's getting darker i still haven't seen
a single person i'm like you know what
in the back of my mind like you still
have at least another two more days
before the water thing really kicks it
so i was like i started to calm down i
started relaxing i'm like let me take a
nap because if i burn up my energy now
in the sun i'm gonna be useless when
they actually find me all right so when
you close your eyes you're not worried
you're never going to open them again
you're not thinking about paralyzation
at this point or what the rest of your
life is going to be like when you get
out of this because you're sure you're
going to be found
yeah so there was a reason i survived
the fall like if i
nobody else should survive a 60-foot
fall unless you have to finish something
here on the planet you got to do
something somewhere teach talk to
somebody something so
that that kept me going that that held
my attitude positive the whole way
through like i didn't even think of oh
man this is gonna suck how am i gonna
explain this to my parents all that like
none of that even crossed my mind i'm
just like you know what i'm alive [ __ ]
i'm i'm here that's all that matters so
now it's around night time and i finally
hear a car door
so i hear a car door and then i hear
faintly my name and i was just like
oh [ __ ] somebody's looking for me so i
first i call out my sister's name
because it sounded like my sister
because my sister's name is anna and i
was dating a girl at the time named
hannah so i yell out anna and i hear a
response i'm thinking oh [ __ ] my sister
found me thank [ __ ] god
so
i'm waiting i'm calling back and forth
she runs up on me she sees me in the
woods the first thing i say is like wait
quick before you say or do anything
call life alert i've fallen and i can't
get up
oh [ __ ]
he starts ugly crying heavy wow no look
for real you got to call the cops
because i can't move
so
we get the cops it takes him like 20 30
minutes to get wait what made her go to
that spot
ah so here's the real trick so
her friend her roommate at the time was
driving from our town over to the next
town uh for a booty call or something
and she saw my cop car and called her
and she's like hey i don't know if
you're still looking for him but i think
i just saw his cop car on the side of
the road
at this location
so
and this was right across the street i'm
on my way to get some dick or else i'll
pull over and see if he is alright you
understand
basically yeah basically i got
priorities i don't know if it was him
but i'll let you know
on the way back after i get [ __ ] on
the way back i'll let you know if this
car is still there
yeah
so
gonna
it also saved you though it did say yeah
exactly exactly exactly that's why i
can't be mad it just saved my life
so
she comes she calls the cops the cops
show up and
all of a sudden there's the squads of
cops coming into the woods firefighters
they got the local boy scouts
involved for what what the [ __ ] they
need to be there
so where i fell right around like not
even a mile away is a boy scout camp and
i guess they were doing like an outing
or something so they figured hey that's
a way to get them a badge let's call
them in too come on
i have a human chain of firefighters
cops and boy scouts just
lifting me out of the woods they put me
in an aspen collar chained me up so i
can't move my neck cut my clothes off
and just start carrying me out so it
takes them like they told me like an
hour to get me out of the woods because
of all it's so rocky and it's it's black
at this point are they telling you
um okay your arm's broken are they
telling you anything that's happening
while you're they're just getting you
the [ __ ] out of there yeah so at this
point i'm still in that good mind state
where i'm just like hey guys how's it
going what's up like yeah i fell off
this cliff like this happened
uh so i'm not processing the the bad
parts of it i'm not processing any of
the damages i'll deal with that when i'm
in the hospital bed so i'm still good
spirits even in the uh police report
they wrote he was in great spirits when
we found him
but um so they get me out they get me
into this ambulance because they can't
land a helicopter where i'm at because
i'm right where there's like a an old uh
native american village that they
recreated waterloo village out by us so
they can't land the helicopter anywhere
there they got to go over to one field
over so they drive me in this ambulance
to the helicopter and it's like it's
like a story the moment i get into the
helicopter a torrential downpour hits
like to the point where you couldn't see
this farm
i hadn't even thought about rain hadn't
even thought about rain yeah yeah no
so so is your sister allowed in there
with you too is she in there with you
so no at this point it's just me in the
helicopter my parents got the call they
told them to go to morristown medical up
in morristown new jersey that's what
they're shipping me off to i'm like yeah
man i love it i've never been in a
helicopter like i asked the guy hey man
can i sit up and see out the window and
he's like bro you look like a semi hit
you there's no way in hell
we're gonna let you sit up
[Music]
so my eyes are like black and blue my
face is just all poppy like i barely
know what i actually did they're not
telling me anything i'm like so wait
hold on here's a question because you
don't know what you [ __ ] look like
except for what you can see at the time
so when are you starting to see your are
they showing you photos are they putting
a mirror in front of you like how do you
know your face is all [ __ ] up they're
not they're not telling me they're just
saying they're not showing me they say
you look [ __ ] up like we don't want to
show you you just you look [ __ ] up
okay all right so they get me in the
chopper and they just start pumping me
with anything they can to sweat to get
rid of the swelling the pain i'm like
guys i don't have any pain i don't need
any benzos i'm fine they're like no no
no this this this like the list of drugs
that they pumped into me in that
helicopter was ridiculous so they land
me in the hospital
at this point i'm like all right i'm
finally safe and i my body just shuts
down like it finally relaxed to the
point where i just went to sleep
and then i think i woke up for maybe
five minutes the next day
like after like they started all these
surgeries i started with
lower half trauma then i upgraded to
full body trauma
basically i oh man so it started with
the hole in my head
uh ended up getting an infection now
if i didn't poke my hole open
right
that infection would have spread to my
brain because i poked it open it
attracted
uh flies that night when i was laying in
the woods from the dirt from the leaves
that i made the pillow under my bed and
those flies ate away the infection the
magic get the [ __ ] out of here yeah the
doctors told you that the doctors told
me that getting the [ __ ] out of here
yeah you avoided a brain infection like
they told my parents basically like your
son is going to be biting his ear for
the rest of his life like
like for the rest of his life
i'm not going to be walking they
basically told my parents like listen
your kid is a vegetable and within two
weeks i was like talking i was like i'm
fine i'll be fine the whole thing they
did oh wait wait so let's go back there
they actually did tell
i thought you were saying that if you
didn't do that that's but they actually
told your parents your son yeah yeah
they told my parents yeah they told them
worst case scenario they didn't know
what was going to happen to me because
every half an hour they discover
something new that's going wrong with my
body from my kidneys shutting down to my
bladder backing up like all these
problems just start appearing
my parents finally get home from that
first night at the hospital like four in
the morning they go to sleep and i
needed emergency surgery and my mom's
phone was on vibrate so she couldn't she
didn't get the call they made the
executive decision to give me emergency
uh scalp surgery because uh my like then
the inflammation from my brain and the
skull from the trauma just started
getting more and more so they had to
they had to basically cut open a a spot
to relieve all that pressure listen man
i don't want to come across racist or
anything here but you sure something
didn't happen on that native american
reservation with the whole scalp thing
you're sure you're sure you sure
so that's why i love the fact that i was
so in tune with nature before this and i
will always respect nature after this
whole thing because nature kept me alive
so
they had emergency surgery on me and
then now we're starting to get a list of
all the things that i [ __ ] up so all
right
besides cracking my skull open i busted
this clavicle open so they had to
basically put rods and pins in that to
hold it straight because that was
snapped in half somehow i powderized the
carpels in my right wrist so
powder it's a term i've i know exactly
what it means but i've never heard it
used for the human but what do you
described
powderized like they said it looks like
sand in there your tendons
the bones the bones in my wrist turn to
powder basically powder yeah they were
so they could not repair them there were
so many little pieces that they were
just like bro we can't do anything for
you
so what they did was they took my hand
and they cut it open right here and
right here and right here and they put
like a uh
like a rod in there with some pins to
hold it straight so that stayed in for
like three months until the bones regrow
from the calcium and everything hold on
you're telling me that bones are
resilient enough to go they can go from
powder to regrowing
so it just depends on how how much bone
is left there like if you have like
there was just so many little chunks
that the little chunks were able to
regrow the existing from the existing
bone but the ones that were really gone
like i can't bend my wrist all the way
like i got half abandoned because it'll
never get that full range of motion
because of the fact that it was frozen
still and it's missing some pieces now
right so
that's the wrist then i
tore the joints in my left knee when i
landed i guess i just tore that right
into my quad so that just they had to
open up my knee from the back and sew me
up oh [ __ ] so so i have this wicked cool
scar on my knee with like lumps and
stuff
i don't know yeah i [ __ ] said yeah
god damn yeah and then um i had a couple
wounds like scratch this open scratched
a couple places on my leg open but
nothing spinal
oh yeah i was going to say for you to
drop like that and land on your feet
your back the big one yeah so that so
that was the big one uh so i blew out my
uh intervertebral discs of my t1 through
t5 vertebrae
oh my god
yeah
are you shorter are you shorter now no
no because they fused me they fused me
back up
but um the way i landed could not have
been any more perfect the way the doctor
described because they gave you a 10.
they hit you with a 10. huh yeah oh yeah
the shock went through and didn't didn't
like i didn't bend so my if i bent in
any way my spine would have snapped in
half but the way i landed it's like i
literally let the like the shock go
right through my body you're a miracle
so you're if your spine bends you're
dead if you don't poke the hole in your
head you're [ __ ] dead yeah yeah
exactly i mean man all these all these
little things that i didn't think that
like i pick up on just watching survival
tv and like different reality shows and
it's like all that stuff comes into play
when you need it and i wonder if it's
winter
and you do this
there's i i don't think there's going to
be flies in the winter oh no i mean
you're dead
yeah right away dead right away
[ __ ]
yeah
so my spine i was fused up this had
metal in it my wrist had metal the one
thing they did miss is i broke my big
toe but there was so much other stuff
going on they didn't notice it so that
just healed on its own it was purple for
like two or three months but when it
healed the bone just healed straight it
doesn't bend at the joint so my big toe
just flops around now
but other than that um lost like 60
pounds in muscle and weight
all right so let me backtrack a little
bit so after that first night after they
they gave the list of everything that
was wrong with me they started doing
emergency surgery sewing me up so it was
like they had to induce me into a coma
because
if i woke up i would just freak out i
remember the first time i woke up
after the fall i saw the breathing tube
in me
and i was strapped like i couldn't move
so i was like well if i can't move i
don't want this thing in my throat
because it's uncomfortable so i bit
through the breathing tube damn right
so
that was a stupid mistake because that
just started pumping all this oxygen
into my lungs and gave me a respiratory
infection so
now they had to because of that they had
to put me into another coma that way i
wouldn't do that again
so
now i'm in an induced coma for about a
week
yeah
for like a week while they fix me up
because every time i wake up for like
five or six seconds i would just be like
what are you doing where am i let go of
me get this out of me like
i would be freaking out i mean they had
me on so many different drugs it makes
sense like i'm hallucinating when i wake
up at one point i'm like i see them
wrapping things around me i'm like am i
being mummified did you guys take my
brain already
you take my brain already
like oh man at one point i thought i was
in the korean war
did you really
oh yeah were you korean were you korean
i was american
because you could have been yeah so i
wake up and i'm like i don't remember
something somebody said something about
korea and then my nurse walks out and
she's asian i didn't know i'm just like
god damn koreans
so in my mind i'm just i'm all over the
place like
uh i remember at one point somebody came
to visit me and they just knocked so
quietly and said hello and i just go
right into lionel richie he's like is it
me
i thought you were like shut this
[ __ ] up
yeah
put his ass in a coma for a week yeah
exactly that's basically what they have
to do
the nurse the nurses loved me because it
was hilarious anytime i'd wake up it'd
be like five minutes of comedy out for
another day
so it was great in that sense but
once i finally like this is like two
weeks in when when all the surgeries are
done and now i'm finally waking up
longer than five minutes and they're
like all right here's what what happened
they filled me in and the whole story
i'm just like wait i broke this when did
i do this like i didn't realize i did
all this damage so let me ask you this
while we're on this moment here
they're they're filling you in on the
story what in your mind is the last
flash that you remember before
it all goes away
um
[Music]
during the story or i mean your fault
when you're no no you're from your fall
like
there's obviously they're filling you in
on stuff you don't know but what do you
remember last was it the slo-mo fall off
the cliff and hitting your feet or do
you remember that that [ __ ] hit
i mean yeah that hit i could taste it on
the back of my mouth still
oh yeah like every once in a while it's
like a tack
yeah
it's like i i feel like this is what it
would feel like to get hit by lightning
that that's the same feeling it feels
like i i can understand
quick and sharp and just metallic
but
so that that was uh basically that was
the last thing i remember from the most
significant part of it the rest of it
was just like i laid there i was calm
some animal came by all that
miscellaneous stuff but that
connection with the ground when i
connected with my right foot i will
never forget that like
i mean to this day my right foot slaps a
little bit when i walk because that's
what took the brunt of the impact my
ankle really absorbed me i'm surprised i
didn't break my ankle i'm saying how's
the how's that [ __ ] and your knees not
powderized and [ __ ] yeah i can't get
over that
like it was just even the doctors like
there's no reason why you are alive
today like the way that you landed what
you did it's like you have training in
all this i was like i watched a lot of
survival tv
man so
um
you mentioned like how was walking after
things like did you need a wheelchair do
you need crutches what oh and also how
long are you in this hospital okay so
i'm in this hospital
they got uh probably for three weeks
they have me in and out going uh
basically i'm staying in the room but
they're pulling me to do surgeries and
i had to get a catheter put in for a
while which ended up
backing up which is a whole nother
freaking set of problems when that
happens
but my bladder swelled up to the size of
a basketball one night oh and nobody
yeah and nobody freaking checked on the
catheter to see if it was draining or
anything so when they come and check on
me in the morning the bag was empty and
they're like uh we don't know anything
about this so they just ignore it uh now
mind you this is a whole day that i'm
not going to the bathroom my body's in
pain once they finally
pull the catheter out it literally
shoots blood across the room oh they
[ __ ] yeah they put a new one in and
drain out probably a liter and a half
out of me oh my god so so what happened
was because the old catheter wasn't
changed it got blocked and the the p
just kept filling my bladder and they
had me on i uh saline the iv so they're
pumping me full of fluids but the fluids
aren't going anywhere so my is just
stretching and stretching and my bladder
lining got so torn from the stretching
that when it receded it was like a
balloon that deflated it was all like
wrinkly and torn up and like
overstretched so
that ended up causing
a whole mess of problems with uh kidney
stones and bladder stones forming from
from the scarring of the bladder
so that was like i'm still kind of work
dealing with that two years later just
the last leg of it but
that that was probably the most annoying
out of the whole thing it wasn't losing
my legs it wasn't anything it was the
freaking kidney and bladder cells
so i have kid i've had kidney stones
i can't believe that you're telling me
that's the worst part because i [ __ ]
had the man that [ __ ] almost wrecked me
it did yeah it did yeah it's what made
me find out i had a blood disease in my
in my body i had no idea i had this
blood disease until the kidney stones
came along and started clotting my legs
and everything i was [ __ ] oh yeah
um
three weeks is it and then you're out at
what home or are you like physical
therapy like what happened
they send me from there they send me
from the hospital to a sub-acute rehab
because i
did not have enough strength in my legs
to go to like a kessler or like an acute
rehab where they really put you to work
so they sent me to like a
a smaller one where you can rest more
and work out like once or twice a day
and what type of people are you meeting
there what sort of injuries are you
seeing in people in this facility in a
sub-acute it was a lot of just older
people it was a lot of elderly people
that fell did little things like that it
was more like uh kind of felt like more
like a retirement home more than
anything
but they had nurses they had a physical
therapist they had a pool so they got
people on the at this point like i
couldn't even i was in a wheelchair like
i had my collar and my arms that was all
well i had use of a wheelchair they had
a catheter in
a nurse was coming to wipe my butt every
time i needed my ass wipe so
that was happening um so at this point
i'm not doing much pt i'm just trying to
circulate my leg i'm just pumping my
ankles i'm just putting like a five
pound weight on my foot just trying to
get anything i can to get blood flowing
through my legs each day i'll notice
like a toe move or uh some finger move
something a little bit more which is why
that kept me
like positive in this whole this whole
problem i never let it get to me until
the day where i saw no progress like
every day from the falls like all right
i might have lost my legs but at least i
see a little bit of them coming back
they they uh first it was the big toe
then it was all the toes then i could
bend my ankle then it was my knee it was
just like slowly every day there'd be
something that i could
just keep me positive about the recovery
like there wouldn't be something to beat
me down like oh [ __ ] i didn't do
anything today i feel useless like i
feel weak i never let that get to me
right so i'm in this sub-acute rehab for
about
give or say like a month where they try
to they got my legs moving a little bit
they got um
some sort of motion my knees started to
unlock a little bit but it wasn't much
work but the one problem i did have
there was
one time they were transferring me from
my wheelchair back into the bed now they
need like three or four people to do
this just to lift me and all this so
they're training me
into doing it myself uh so that i got to
the point where i was confident enough
in my own
hands to hold the chair and like lift
slightly and just shift myself over
but um
the nurse at the time didn't see that i
had my catheter bag hanging on the
wheelchair god damn
so once i shift onto the bed she pulls
the wheelchair up so fast and literally
almost pulls me off the bed by my dick
like it was the most painful feeling in
the world like i just that's when i
broke into tears i think that was the
first time i broke into tears was a bad
moment i was like oh
but
it's all right [ __ ] at that point it's
like the pain went away after an hour
they gave me a pain pill
whatever it happens like she didn't see
i it's it's all right i mean i'm still
here i'm still alive i'm still
recovering so that didn't didn't kill me
but
it definitely sucked how i've talked to
other people who've had to learn how to
walk again or at least so i'm assuming
your legs were [ __ ] for a while and
they talk about the mental
struggle because
muscle memory your mind remembers how to
do this but you can't communicate to
your [ __ ] legs hey one after the
other so where
tell me about that so i remember waking
up like the first time i had an act like
i
since i smoked a lot of weed before the
fall i didn't really dream much this is
the first time i dreamed since the fall
and i dreamt of running like i remember
waking up from that dream and just
looking at my legs and like all right
move and i couldn't even get my ankle to
move i'm like this is [ __ ] like how
like i know how to move it i'm i'm
pumping i'm moving but nothing so i'm
just like all right whatever i'll work
with what i got so i have a toe moving
so i just kept working that toe and then
the muscle memory came back to the other
toe and then the joint and i was like
all right if i just keep working this
it'll all come back it's just going to
take a lot longer now at this point my
legs look like somebody just stuck a
straw in them and sucked out all the
juice because it's just bone and
skin like it was just nothing compared
to what i looked like before
i mean if it wasn't for me being in such
good shape when i fell i definitely
would have died because i that that was
another fact that kept me alive was the
fact that i was
decently toned and my body was was more
resilient than most people
so
just being like all sucked out and bony
and scrawny was definitely like
unmotivating because i i could see like
man i can't move this but i know i will
be able to as soon as i get that muscle
back so i just have to find ways to
recover the muscle anything i can do
so
after a month in this uh one rehab in
lincoln park new jersey they moved me to
a kessler spinal rehab in
i think east orange here in jersey and
that's like supposed to be the number
one spinal rehabilitation place in
jersey like they they pride themselves
on helping people get back on their feet
so
i get there and then within the first
day they just start like three hours of
pt ot like they drill me like i came
from basically a daycare to a boot camp
okay all right i see
yeah they're like bro you you just spent
the last
last month not developing so mass on
your legs we're gonna get you on your
feet in the next month so
uh within the first day they do their
evaluation they see how much i can
actually take like how much my feet can
handle like they're like all right we
know you can't stand up but you're gonna
have to try to stand up and show us what
you're capable of so i'm petrified like
i'm shaking like a leaf this is the
first time you've tried yeah yeah
and of course i freaking don't even get
like an inch off with a seat without
sitting down
and then just sit down but
at that moment i'm like you know what if
i hadn't tried to even sit up now i
would have never even known i could do
it so that was another big motivational
step so like all right i'm moving my
feet and i can slowly lift myself what's
next what's going to come next what am i
going to get my full backpack what's
going to what's going to recover my full
back back
i'm probably going to get my full back
back
am i gonna get my back back
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
oh [ __ ] dude so
at this point i mean i'm the pain in my
spine will they fuse me has been num num
and now i'm starting to actually feel
the throbbing and all this so i'm like
all right this is something i'm gonna
have to live with and are you also just
being pumped full of uh pain meds and
[ __ ] too
yeah yeah so they started to wean me off
because i was getting constipated i was
getting the side effects like all right
we got to get you off of this because
it's not doing you justice i was like
that's right i don't want to get
addicted to this when you let me out
because i know way too many people in
jersey that have problems with that [ __ ]
and i did not want to get involved
so they start weaning me off winning me
off i'm i think i'm down to like one or
two oxy cottons a day just for pt like i
needed that i had my friends
smuggle me in some cbd gummies at one
point i had a friend of mine bring me a
freaking bag of regular gummies
just to deal get get rid of that pain on
my own like i'm gonna do without
pharmaceuticals at least i know what's
in the gummy
so
uh slowly i'm working on pt we're
getting back into it and then i get a
new roommate in my at kessler or uh at
the rehab and this dude
is like maybe 10 years older than me but
he has generally the same spinal problem
as me
but
he like lost use of his legs but his
thing wasn't from a fall he he just had
a pinched nerve so me and him we we hit
it off real quick well he had a [ __ ]
pinched nerve and lost use of his legs
so he was a heavier set dude and he was
walking his dog and something he stepped
wrong and a nerve pinched in one of his
vertebrae and completely cut off the use
of his legs and he dropped in the
streets damn
i didn't know i didn't know that could
happen
yeah i didn't either and he's like yeah
bro this is oh i mean he was like almost
300 something pounds so that's probably
a factor in it but
he freaking he had to recover his legs
same as me and i'm like all right so
we're going to have someone to compare
progress to so we're kicking it we're
bullshitting he's got some friends
coming over and bringing some paper pens
we're basically throwing a party at the
kessler like right after pt it's our
shot like we're doing what we want
whatever so i see him start recovering
faster he gets out of his wheelchair
onto the walker now i'm like god damn
man i'm still in this damn wheelchair
you're out here on the walker like i
know you're gonna be you're gonna be
fine man if you got it i know i'll i'll
get it no problem
so
he's recovering i'm recovering we're in
the same like we got the same pt people
we got the same oats i set everything up
for us like yo let me get work with him
like we work great together so
basically within a month of being at
this kessler i'm now
finally able to stand on my feet in a
machine like they have this like
standing machine where you go from
sitting to standing and then they'll see
how long you can stand based on your own
strength so there's like a table you put
your hands on and then you stand
and then eventually like if it's too
weak they can lower you back into the
sitting position without uh without too
much uh struggle so they get me standing
i'm fine like yo bro i get back to the
room i'm like yeah man i finally got to
stand up he's like
great man i'm leaving i was like
what the [ __ ] how are you leaving like
we just i just got progress we're
supposed to do this together it's like
nah man i gotta go like my insurance is
up so i was like all right bro keep in
touch let me grab your number so i'm
still in good good contact with him i
check up on him yeah
but so
he leaves i get a new roommate and then
me and this dude same thing we hit it
off and now
we're recovering i'm he's a little bit
more [ __ ] up than me because i've been
there for a month but this dude that
comes in same thing doesn't move and i'm
like yeah bro listen
i did it you'll be fine don't be down on
yourself and i told them my story like i
shouldn't be here i recovered from this
down a third like i broke all of this
stuff and i'm walk like i'm standing on
my own legs today and it's only been
three months
like
yeah it's not me standing and walking
but i'm standing with a walker like i'm
able to stand in place so
this is now november i want to say like
beginning of november it's when they
finally let me go home like the day i
get to go home i'm excited i'm ready and
the day my parents come to pick me up
i have the sharpest pain in my side
and it turns out i got a kidney stone
that's my first one so they take me to
back to morristown they check me and
they they do uh they put a stent in my
uh my right kidney to make sure i can
flush out then they notice all these
bladder stones it literally looked like
a geode inside of my bladder like it was
just crystallized from from that from
two months ago when my bladder stretched
out and got all those scars oh [ __ ] so
the first thing they're like have you
been to china recently i'm like what the
[ __ ] that got to do oh well well in
china they have this miners disease
where people uh when exposed to some
sort of chemical get this type of
calcification in their bladder like bro
dude do you look at me do i look like
i've been to china i'm in a
caller in a wheelchair like there's no
it's not happening
so
they're like well this is this is a
strange case so we're going to monitor
this so they
put me under they do like a cisco uh
exam where they go into me and like
literally scrape all the diamonds and
stuff out of me and flush me out right
so i still haven't been home like it's
been three and a half months and i still
have not been home like all i want to do
is just go home and lay in my own bed
so
after
a week of being in the hospital from the
rehab i finally get to go back to my
parents house because i'm still unable
to take care of myself so i can't go
back to my apartment i gotta at least
live with them until i can get back on
my legs or be able to take care of
myself
so
thank god my mom is uh basically she's a
cna but she's gonna become a registered
nurse but she's gonna work with old
people forever so she's been dealing
with weak old people showering people
all this so she's been a saint for the
whole process she took care of me
from the moment i fell she was there
every single day at the hospital took
all her sick days all her vacation days
everything to make sure i recovered
so
anything i could do for my mom i was i
was trying to help her out so while i'm
in her house like even though i'm not
walking i was like hey mom let me let me
do something for let me help you with
because her english is a little poor so
let me help you write some some emails
any way i can because you were there for
me
so
i'm living there i'm starting to get
stronger i'm doing my own pt
at home at the same time i'm getting
brought out to an outpatient pt
uh at that point i think it's
uh now we're in november late november
beginning of december when i really i at
this point i think i'm out of the chair
and just on the walker like i'm still
weak on the walker but at least i'm not
using the chair to get around the house
anymore like i'm pushing myself to get
my feet going
so
uh i'm walking around the house i
finally get outside because it's getting
a little uh it's not too cold in that
december like we've been having hot
decembers lately so i'm outside getting
some fresh air i'm finally walking
around on the driveway with the walker
uh
flash forward to about january when i
finally get off the walker and just get
a cane and from there i just
hustle like i at this point my feet are
like 40 back to it like i could stand on
my feet with a little bit of confidence
as long as i have a surface i'm touching
and i only need one one surface so i'm
like all right i'm getting better i'm
getting stronger so i just focus on just
getting my feet stronger getting my arms
stronger
and
we're in like probably the end of
january beginning of february is when i
finally said all right now i can go back
to my apartment so about six months in
i get back to my my place still going to
pt but
i've actually
gotten back on my own a little bit more
self-sustained
now for a while i mean i was still going
to urologist visits to deal with the
kidney stones and the bladder that kept
reoccurring every month like i kept
passing a stone or two at night and my
bladder got really [ __ ] up yeah i know
it's like flatter stones
they're not as bad as kidney stones but
they you pass them for like three or
four days oh first
you you feel it pass and then for like
three or four days you you can only pee
a little bit and then a little bit more
and it always feels like you gotta go
but these once it does come out it's
like it's like your face somebody
flushed uh uh your face completely out
it's like all pale and then all back to
normal
so
that was annoying to deal with but so
once i got
back on my own i started to recover
and i was like all right let me figure
out at this point where am i going to go
with life because i can't go back to
warehouse work i can barely stand up on
my own feet so i decided at that point
you know what if i do mess something up
again i at least need to know what i did
or what it's called or how to fix it so
i decided to get into massage therapy
even though
yeah even though i'm still not like 100
back to myself i was like let me look
into some information about this um
there was a school not too far from me
that had a year program so i signed up
for the program that started in
september and this was still like
earlier in the year so like by september
i should be back to generally normal
so i started the program in september
by
was it march march is when covet hits so
the program got got shut down for a year
[ __ ]
so i was six months in i mean i had some
hands-on work i had a little bit of a
routine i had the knowledge starting to
build at this point i was just like my
new little classes here and there uh
shiatsu uh reflex little things like
that so let me ask you this where are
you now with um your health and walking
and everything it's been what two and a
half three years
so uh right right now basically yeah i'm
basically like 99
oh wow okay i can you drive again oh
yeah i was driving six months in they
told they told me we don't know when
you'll be driving again i know how to
use a pedal it's fine yeah so
i at this point i mean i could jump
again which i i didn't think i'd be able
to do i can hobble run so i mean i can't
sprint if there's somebody chasing me
[ __ ] take my wallet but i can i can
get away slightly and then i mean i'm
walking again i can ride a bike will you
ever get full 100
uh mobility well i'm not 100 but will
you get even better than where you are
now or is this it
so i i'm pretty sure it's getting better
i mean the bladder is the real thing i'm
still monitoring it's been like two and
a half years and i'm still going to the
doctor for this monitoring what's going
on it's just like peeing a lot
um but when it comes to my back i mean i
the pain that i have now i'm just so
accustomed to and used to that my body
just doesn't even register it as pain
it's just normal yeah so i don't i don't
even remember what it feels like to not
feel this in my back it's just like it
feels like a numb little like
glass clock
uh it's it's like a numb clasping right
right where they fused me it just it
feels like somebody's just holding you
there okay so that's not the worst i
mean it was definitely challenging
getting into massage with this with this
going on because it's a lot of different
positions and a lot of arm and leg work
standing the whole time yeah
so that was great for my pt and
strengthening my core and everything
back so i mean
that was a big thing that helped me
recover even better after my pt was over
was just getting out being physical and
then
since it all these people went out to
fix me like it cost almost half a
million dollars to put me back together
like my mom half million
yeah exactly my mom got the bill thank
god for a good insurance because we
would have been screwed
i'd have been running to canada while
hobbling well thank you thank you andre
for coming on and sharing your story
this has been amazing and i'm glad
you're all right i can't even believe
oh yeah i mean the land on your [ __ ]
feet and here obviously i was wondering
i i didn't expect the kidney stones and
bladder stones i really expected you to
have more problems with your knees and
everything
yeah
um i'm glad you're all right man thank
you so much for coming on and sharing
your story uh and if any of you out
there have a story that needs to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com uh sign up for
a year you'll save a month and you are
now getting the honeydew a day early
ad-free at no additional cost i love you
all thank you for your support and we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
so
[Music]
you